the question does not say i don't know
why i put a plus sign there the question
does not say
get a general term i don't need a
general term um i just need to get to
what this a what what year am i after
have a look at the question
a nine right the end of nine years
according to where i've defined this a9
is the one i'm after okay so looking
carefully
at how this number here the n
interacts with these powers over here
that's a one
and then there's a zero on the end there
okay how does this line
this expression here how does it begin
i'll give you a clue
it starts with a hundred ishan what do
you think
oh sure yeah and the previous sentence
is zero wouldn't that be one then
ah okay so zero would be one uh what i
mean by a zero is it's one point one to
the power of zero so you can see there's
a
two one zero it just counts down okay
but because that is just one
that's this one we kind of don't write
it yeah okay sorry so if you're in the
middle of actually saying what happens
next
um you add bracket 1.1 to the power of
nine
okay let's pause here sorry okay this is
so important i'm trying to emphasize
because this is the place where we all
it's where some people's answers differ
right
i'm going to write down a number here
where do i get it from i'm trying to
follow the pattern i already established
if this is 3 this is 1 less than that
does that make sense
why is it one less by the way
yeah it's from it's from the the oldest
deposit the earliest deposit
but that earliest deposit came at the
end of that first year
so after nine years it's been there for
eight years right it's the nine years
take away the first year when nothing
really happened
make sense okay good next term along the
powers are just going to go
down aren't they right so that'll be a
seven um
i need one more it's gonna be a six and
then
what will the very last term be it'll be
100 because at the end of each year
that's what happens every single time
okay
wonderful now this guy here we can
actually work with this we don't need to
put this all into our calculator we've
done this before what should i say
this is a geometric progression right
i've got a series here
but you don't just want to pull out of a
hat go to the formula immediately you
must identify right
so i'm looking for three things these
are the three the three features
of every gm geometric progression what's
our first term
okay now um i can start on either end
can't i we've done this before
it's going to be easier to start at the
end because then i can say my ratio is
1 1.1 um where i to start from this end
i would have to be dividing by 1.1 not
multiplying by 1.1 to progress along the
series
and that's gross i'd rather not do that
how many terms
look really carefully right now again
this is another place for
problems to creep in when we're counting
right so
yeah right so you can follow this fairly
easily have a look at a1
how many terms does it have one look at
a two how many terms does it have
a three has three terms a nine
will have nine terms you okay with that
so now i'm ready to pop this guy into
the formula
okay can you tell me what the formula is
and substitute in the appropriate stuff
what am i going to begin by writing
have a thing i want i want the formula i
want the formula
100 bracket 1.1 to the power of nine
minus one bracket on top of one point
one minus one
nailed it okay fantastic this guy
you're just doing some mental
calculations for me sorry what do you
got
uh at the one carry the three one
thousand three seven point nine
yay okay nine five nine five yeah
okay i thought it was point oh no jokes
you randomly
is that better yeah okay happy times
it was included in our gp calculation
okay wait what what's your question i
don't see the difference i'm doing it
normally
and then wrong button or i thought it
was
so the first time it's a hundred dollars
then it gets like
of course
you get 231 okay now guys you're 12.
you talk i get that it's the end of the
day there's actually a really important
question here i'm trying to unpack
and i can barely hear it what's the
question serene
i don't know you're distinguishing this
from
some other situation tavar do you want
to try it
every year right and the ratio is 1.1
when you like put
t 2 over t1 wouldn't it be um
your number with a hundred over yeah
instead of like 110 over 100 would be
like 210 or 100.
okay so all right let's think about this
carefully
right tavare's talking about
i'm sure i get the numbers right um
there's a hundred
that's the first one right and then and
then interest happens
yeah and then another installment sorry
that's that was no i was right another
installment happens on top of that yeah
which takes me up to 210
is that okay and then it goes
installment interest
installment next one's interest so
that's
going to be 2 31 and
wait did you get it right yeah that
should be just 231 okay that's 10
i can calculate percentages right now
you're asking tavare about
doing some division right now what were
you dividing this i want to check what
you are talking about
yep but what if you put like
the term with the 100 that's normal
okay all right so the question here is
what's going on when we
like we're building a geometric series
aren't we right so what happens when we
divide
one term by the previous one right
well it's interesting you kind of get
1.1 sometimes
uh you get 1.1 here yeah that's 1.1 you
get 1.1
here but you very do not get it
in here but why is that even in the way
that i was building and writing this
saying this allowed
hopefully you can hear why you don't get
1.1 in that middle one
why not 100 and then 110 but then you
add the 100
on top of that 110 right yeah so
different different things are happening
here
right so what i'm going to say is i'm
going to avoid
this um t1 t2 language when i'm talking
about these because
this is this is not a gp right this is
not a gp
two different things are happening at
the same time installments happen
that's an adding process there's no
multiplication happening geometry
progressions are about
multiplication right and then interest
happens
it's really though only the interest
that creates the
geometric progression does that make
sense it's not the installments
so you'll be careful when you think
about what is t1 and t2 and t3 okay
these guys are t1 t2 and t3
not these guys okay